mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis
chers eric sherjill je voudrais rappeler
deux trois choses pour pour préciser je
ne me souviens pas d'un autre président
de la république que celui qui est
devant vous qui durant son quinquennat
refuser tout coup de pouce au smic
gauche et droite confondues
ça n'était jamais arrivé jamais je ne me
souviens pas d'un autre président un
public où les effectifs de la fonction
publique ont baissé
cent cinquante mille et dont on calcule
sur 2010-2012 faut l'affiner 2007 2012
cent cinquante mille fonctionnaires en
moins et j'avais tous les parlementaires
y compris de la majorité qui disaient
non nicolas tu as raison mais ce
ministère pour le préserver puis et à la
fin vous fut réservé tous les ministères
fait aucune économie
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont arrivés à cela
quand nous avons fait la réforme des
retraites 22 milliards d'euros de
recettes par an avec eric pasin syndicat
n'a voté avec nos voisins
est ce qu'ils ignoraient qu'ils avaient
un problème de financement des retraites
non ce ne sont pas des syndicats ils
étaient dans le combat politique qu'ils
appellent à voter pour françois hollande
qui leur a menti ils ont été trompés
qu'ils en assument les conséquences
nous nous avons sauvé l'équilibré des
régimes l'antenne quand nous avons fait
la réforme
de la carte judiciaire tous les élèves
du lycée du mot dit non mais tu as
raison mais pas mon tribunal c'est ça
qui disait l'enfer c'est les autres
pensent que c'est faux il ya entre
chacun de nous il du paradis d'enfer
on a supprimé le tiers des institutions
des tribunaux le tiers ça m'a fait
plaisir
je me souviens courageusement rachida
dati a conduit cette réforme
je manque un petit peu de soutien
l'époque mais on a tenu
parce que c'est la vérité tout le monde
voulait garder son prime une ald
instance tout le monde voulait garder
son tribunal de grande instance canton à
réformer les régimes spéciaux 2007 neuf
jours de grève
c'était un terrain vierge personnes s'y
étaient attaqués personne absolument
personne
donc je dis ça propos en tirer quelques
gloires que cela soit et quand même ce
que nous avons fait nous l'avons fait
seul contre tous le monde élus
observateurs journalistes spécialistes
surtout les spécialistes
surtout les spécialistes les grands
spécialistes qui on demande de prendre
position
il y en a deux grands talents que j'aime
beaucoup par ailleurs comme jacques
attali mais il a été le conseiller
spécial du président république a voulu
la retraite à 60 ans donc sans doute que
j'ai pas été assez loin à la retraite à
62 ans mais lui il l'a passée de 65 à 60
nos de 60 à 62 ans c'est pas tout à fait
le même chemin et c'est un petit peu
plus difficile alors les choses ayant
évolué il fallait plus loin c'est tout
le travail que nous faisons et merci
véronique jean philippe et bien sûr toi
et eric gil deux d'apporter votre
compétence avec tous les élus qui sont
ici quels problèmes de la france
problème de la france c'est pas d'abord
déficit s'est pas d'abord l'endettement
c'est le montant des dépenses publiques
et je voudrais tellement convaincu mon
propre parti que le problème la cause
c'est le montant des dépenses
la conséquence c'est le déficit est la
conséquence c'est l'endettement pour
faire plus clair les dépenses génèrent
du déficit et l'addition des déficits
génère l'endettement si vous attaquer
aux déficits et à l'endettement sont
vous attaquer aux dépenses vous attaquer
aux conséquences n'attaquez pas à la
cause est ce qu'on est bien clair sur
cette première orientation stratégique
chez christian saint-etienne merci
fondamental dans le projet économique
des républicains c'est fondamental
la cause c'est le montant des dépenses
publiques il ne s'agit pas pour nous
d'une question daniel idéologique d'une
question de gauche de droite de
socialistes de libéralisme
il s'agit d'une question de bon sens
avec 57 5% de montant des dépenses
publiques sera richesse nationale
le pays ne peut pas s'en sortir là est
le problème qui conditionne tous les
autres
absolument tous les autres car le but
que nous avons sur christian c'est pas
de faire mourir la france guiry
c'est de diminuer le montant des
dépenses de redonner de la compétitivité
aux entreprises et créer des emplois
avec de la croissance
c'est ça notre stratégie au fond
diminuer les dépenses mettre
l'entreprise au coeur de toute la
stratégie économique l'entreprise c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga l'entreprise c'est le
commencement et c'est la fin
l'entreprise c'est le coeur d'une
politique économique un pardon de
regarder d'abord les choses d'un point
de vue macroéconomique
je rentrerai bien surprise donc dans le
détail mais vous bien comme monza on
baisse les dépenses ont défini une
politique économique de façon à mettre
nos entreprises en situation de gagner
des parts de marché et de prendre de la
concurrence d'abord sur leur marché
premier marché européen
ensuite sur le marché international
naturellement il s'agit pas de nous
mettre dans les mêmes conditions que les
entreprises chinoises que les
entreprises indiennes que les
entreprises brésiliennes
il s'agit comme objectif de mettre nos
entreprises au niveau de fiscalité
moyens de l'entreprise européenne
l'entreprise européenne vous comprenez
déjà six sur votre marché premier vous
êtes en situation qu'on plante c'est
notre vision et c'est notre objectif
elle troisième élément de cette
politique économique est définie par les
républicains c'est que les classes
moyennes sont le coeur de la cible
économique pour nous il n'y aura pas de
prospérité pour la france il n'y aura
pas de retour au plein emploi
si les classes moyennes continue à être
pris sur est accablé d'impôt est accablé
de charge
voilà
j'espère que claude mes amis vous n'êtes
pas contre eux contre ça mais je sais
pas du tout le disque où j'avais prévu
de faire mais peu importe c'est gilles
qui m'inspiraient donc bon mais en tout
cas c'est vraiment ce que je crois non
mais très important que vous compreniez
parce que si vous comprenez les français
nous comprenons diminution des dépenses
en entreprise et le coeur de la
politique économique et les classes
moyennes ne peuvent pas être les oubliés
du choc fiscal ou du pacte de
redressement que nous proposons à la
france si après il faut préciser c'est
très important
est ce qu a dit gilles je me reconnais
totalement n'a encore travailler
dimanche avec eric sur cette question on
va faire quelque chose qui ne s'est
jamais fait et qui s'appelle la
simultanéité parce que nous ne sommes
pas des comptables nous sommes des
responsables politiques qui devons
imaginer une politique économique avec
une vision avec une dynamique
naturellement que les dépenses c'est
pour tout de suite et que les
économistes dans le temps c'est ce que
me la vision comptable des choses j'ai
rien contre consisterait à attendre que
les économies produisent des effets pour
gager des baisses d'impôts ça c'est dans
un monde idéal et je veux en parler avec
vous parce que dans ce monde-là idéal ça
voudrait dire que la parole publique est
encore du poids et que la croissance
vient naturellement chez nous ce n'est
pas le cas il ne sert à rien de parler
de baisse d'impôts sans les faire
j'attire vraiment votre attention
là dessus je parle devant des
parlementaires amis je parle devant des
amis mais ça ne sert à rien donc
ce que nous disons tous ensemble le
projet des républicains c'est que c'est
juillet 2017
trois projets qui arrivent ensemble
projet de réduction des dépenses
publiques pour 100 milliards projet de
baisse des impôts 25 milliards et projet
de refondation du code social
on en parlera ensemble pourquoi ensemble
parce que on doit rassurer
bien sûr les marchés les grands agrégats
parce qu'on doit continuer à emprunter
et nos partenaires européens
il s'agit pas là non plus de promettre
des réformes pour les faire les
meilleures façons de les faire c'est de
les voter et en même temps ou en coupant
de la dépense au moment vous couper de
la dépense ça forcément un effet
récessif sur le moment vous le faites
c'est absolument évident si vous ne le
compensent et pas par des démissions
normes par une refondation du code
social par une baisse immédiate des
impôts au fond vous aggraver le problème
est-ce que je je je vous fais comprendre
c'est quelqu'un par exemple qui on
soumet un traitement très difficile nous
donne pas de vitamines il va guérir de
la maladie qui la met va mourir d'une
autre bon c'est quand même pas le budget
annonce mais on a quand même un peu
réfléchi à ça on a débattu de sanaa
c'est extrêmement important j'espère que
ça ne vous ennuie pas mon raisonnement
comme ça mais c'est c'est pour remettre
dans un contexte et pour que vous voyez
comment on peut rassembler une famille
politique et proposer une vraie
stratégie économique
un pays alors sur les économies les
économies on peut faire le tour des
choses ça passe d'abord puisque on
dépense trop il ya trop de dépenses
publiques par la sphère publique
tout ce qu'on veut et comme la plus de
la moitié du budget dès le premier
budget de la nation éducation nationale
c'est faux c'est la faulx l'endettement
et deuxièmement c'est un masse salariale
tout ce qu'on veut c'est ça donc il ya
un problème d'effectifs dans la fonction
publique qui est incontournable
absolument incontournable il s'agit pas
de vouloir pénaliser les fonctionnaires
il s'agit pas dire que les
fonctionnaires on n'en veut pas
rencontrez vous savez quand il ya une
crise on est bien contents de trouver
des services publics qui marche
donc il faut aller secourir des gens
montagne quand il faut aller se battre
au bataclan parce qu'elle est barbare
qui ont pris en otage
quand il ya une catastrophe on est bien
content d'avoir service public et chez
les républicains
nous n'acceptons pas une dénonciation
collective des fonctionnaires la plupart
des fonctionnaires font parfaitement
dans leur travail sont des gens qui
aiment leur travail et dont nous avons
besoin
on n'est pas pour passer d'un trop
d'état a pas d'état simplement via un
problème d'effectif donc nous proposons
de reprendre le un sur deux pourquoi je
ne souhaite pas qu'on aille plus loin
pour une raison très simple si vous
faites aucun remplacement qu'est ce que
deviennent les écoles de formation vous
les occuper pas pendant deux ans pendant
trois ans et qu'est-ce que vous gardez
dans vos corps va vous regarder les plus
âgés à mon âge maintenant on peut le
dire
sens 1 ou ceux qui sont pas forcément
les plus dynamiques mais on propose un
changement colossal
c'est une réforme de la constitution je
sais que ça fait débat y compris notre
propre parti pour imposer aux
collectivités territoriales le un sur
deux comme nous l'avons fait pour l'état
ça c'est un changement majeur
beaucoup plus importants comme le croire
et cher eric gergy vous savez que il ya
des protestations aussi chez les
républicains
mais l'arbitrage que nous vous proposons
parce que pendant mon quinquennat
supprimer 150 mille postes de
fonctionnaires d'état et les
collectivités territoriales
majoritairement dirigées par la gauche
on en crée autant dont crise les
déficits qui s'accumulent donc ça c'est
un changement un deuxième chose qui va
avec et qui est extraordinairement
difficile c'est qu'on ne peut pas parce
que ça ne serait pas honnête dire qu'on
diminue de 300 mille le nombre de
fonctionnaires sur un quinquennat sans
augmenter la durée de travail pendant
six ans n'a - il faudra que ceux qui
font qu'ils sont moins nombreux travail
plus parce que si on ne peut mais pas
clairement sur la table la question de
la durée de travail dans les services
publics
là la stratégie qu'on dise consisterait
à diminuer la qualité de service public
qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec ça pour les
collectivités locales
d'abord nous demandons à ce que tous les
services sur les 35 heures ce n'est pas
le cas si on ne le dit pas on passe à
côté de la réalité
je ne dénonce personnes peu de reproche
à personne
simplement il ya des tas de
collectivités ou les services sont à 28
heures ou à 32 heures premières bases
tout le monde au minimum à 35 heures
pour l'état nous proposons de passer à
37 heures payées 37
mais passer à 37 heures le passage de 28
à 35 même salaire 1,37 eur pour les
collectivités territoriales sur année
c'est aux collectivités territoriales de
décider car nous souhaitons rendre aux
exécutifs territoriaux la liberté de
discuter annuler les accords de
réduction du temps de travail de jospin
début d année 2007 aux collectivités
territoriales de décider est ce qu'elles
vont à 37
est ce qu'elles vont à 38 est ce
qu'elles vont à 39 est-ce qu'elle reste
à 35
c'est un changement colossal
j'ajoute à cela que nous souhaitons
généralisée permettre et quand même
généraliser l'emploi du contrat dans la
fonction publique
tout le monde n'a pas vocation est
fonctionnaire avis on doit pouvoir
recruter sur la base de contrats dans la
fonction publique ce qui redonnera aux
exécutifs une capacité à gérer
j'ajoute un détail qui semble
techniquement et est très important
c'est une proposition d'eric woerth je
remercie pour les élus territoriaux
on va supprimer a à peu près la moitié
de l'évolution du gvt glissement
vieillesse technicité qui fait que sans
que les exécutifs territoriaux décide de
quoi que ce soit il ya 2,5 à 3 points de
masse salariale de plus pour des raisons
catégorielles nous voulons supprimer la
moitié c'est-à-dire qu'on veut remplacer
toute une partie de l'avancement à
l'ancienneté pas de l'avancement au
mérite
on croit au travail on croit à l'effort
on croit au mérite donc qu'on en tire
les conséquences
là il ya déjà sherjill de quoi bien
occuper l'été
bon alors je me reconnais dans ce qu'il
a dit hier christian aussi le social
une fois qu'on a dit le social il faut
s'incliner plus personne ne sait ce que
ça veut dire si ce n'est que quand on
n'est pas social on n'est pas généreux
et quand données sociales on dépense
l'argent qu'on n'a pas donc grosso modo
en faire un résumé à peu près de la
situation alors sur le social
qu'est ce qu'on va faire à faire tout de
suite la retraite
moi ça fait bien longtemps que j'ai
perdu
l'idée qu'il existait une réforme
parfaite qui sauve des le problème
complètement le monde bush
la société évolue je ne crois plus à la
réforme si tu définitive vous la faites
vous avez tout régler en fait rien réglé
du tout donc on
une année d'espérance de vie à un
trimestre d'espérance de vie chaque
année c'est normal que la réforme des
retraites soit progressive
donc nous proposons 63 ans comme âge de
départ à la retraite ne parle pas de la
décote
c'est beaucoup plus tard 63 ans en 2020
64 en 2025 avec ça en garantit la
pérennité de l'équilibré de l'assurance
vie est déjà pas si mal
et naturellement suppression immédiate
du comte de pénibilité parce que le
compte de pénibilité s'est à nouveau
régime spécial qu'est ce que c'est
j'ajoute qu'elle a caractérisé qu'à la
différence de fléchissait ça entre eux
un métier et un hobby aux données
solution le métier c'est pénible lobby
s'est jamais penning parce que si ça
devient pénible d'un métier ou alors on
est maso vous pouvez aimer votre métier
d'une façon extraordinaire
il ya toujours des moments où c'est
pénible qu'elle est l'institutrice
passionné de son métier qui ne dira pas
tant certains jours avoir trente enfants
mon dieu telle est la secrétaire qui
travaillent devant un écran qui à un
moment ou un autre dira pas c'est
fatigant tous les métiers sont fatigants
si vous rentrez dans la pénibilité
vous rentrez dans un système où vous
multiplierez les régimes spéciaux et on
vous créerez beaucoup de frustration et
beaucoup d'injustice parce que
naturellement celui d'à côté dira mais
mon métier il est aussi pénible pourquoi
je suis pas pénible situé pénible toi
mais ton métier non
j'arrête pas de dire si jolie il faut
qu'un certain nombre d'observateurs
évolué dans le raisonnement l'époque où
il y avait la machine à vapeur
il fallait chargés de charbon on inhale
est tout ceci dans les poumons et
maintenant mon pilote un dgb sa patte
tout à fait la même chose donc on
supprime le comte pénibilité et pendant
qu'on y est on supprime les régimes
spéciaux
je préfère qu'on le dise au casier aux
électriciens aux cheminots aux postiers
et nous faisons quelque chose qui est
encore plus important il ya le mot
égalité au frontispice de tous nos
équipements publics
on décidera dès juillet 2010 est que les
conditions pour partir à la retraite et
pour calculer ces retraites dans le
public et donc privé sont les mêmes ça
veut dire quoi concrètement cela
signifie que le montant de la retraite
sera calculée sur le salaire des 25
dernières années et non pas sur les six
derniers mois et cela signifie aussi
qu'il faudra intégrer les primes dans le
calcul
mais je préfère prévenir les primes
seront chargés enfin quand j'ai chargé
des cotisations ne peux pas me dire les
prix on les met dans le calcul des
retraites mais elles sont sans
cotisation ne peut pas pas enfin il ya
des restaurants qui vous fromage et
dessert mais là compte tenu de la
situation de disette budgétaire
ça sera pas comme ça j'ajoute pour être
tout à fait sûre d'être compris qu'on
appliquera les mêmes règles de jours de
carence dans public et en privé
alors oui jean-félix je sais il ya une
différence
nous avions avec françois fillon rétabli
jour de carence vraiment monsieur
hollande qui n'a pas loupé une la
supprimés dans le privé ces trois jours
mais il faut dire oui oui mais il faut
être très honnête tu as beaucoup
d'entreprises qui le prennent en charge
un ou deux jours non mais il faut qu'ils
les rachète donc il faudrait essayer
d'être je crois qu'elle contrat de
confiance avec les français par partira
de notre lucidité et donc nous proposons
deux jours dans le public restera et à
beaucoup d'autres choses de dossiers
extrêmement important le premier c'est
l'assurance chômage
d les chiffres c'est très simple en 2018
l'assurance chômage aurait une dette de
35 milliards d'euros c'est assez
symbolique c'est une année de cotisation
des entreprises
ça peut pas durer comme ça donc nous
proposons quelque chose de très franc de
reprendre que l'état reprenne la gestion
du régime parce qu'on n'a pas
l'intention d'attendre que les
partenaires sociaux se regardant dans le
blanc des yeux prennent le temps de
mesurer la catastrophe on remet
l'assurance chômage
decker en équilibre et le temps qu'il
n'est pas un équilibre c'est l'état qui
gère et cela veut dire très clairement
la réintroduction des paliers de
dégressivité il n'ya pas d'incitation à
reprendre un emploi sont dégressivité
alors il faut aussi mettre un peu de
temps nous on en a beaucoup parlé
moi je pense que le choc du chômage
s'est ain chock vous laisser autant de
gens dessous retournez premier palier de
dégressivité 12 mois
parce qu'on a un an pour se retourner un
palier d'au moins 20% deuxième palier de
dégressivité 18 mois un autre 20 po
j'ajoute également là dessus par dont
j'espère que j'aime pas trop de détails
mais pour vous montrer le sérieux du du
travail que nous avons voulu faire c'est
qu'on ne peut pas allonger la durée de
vie au travail et ne pas en tenir compte
pour les règles de durée d'indemnisation
de ce qu'on appelle les seniors ou les
plus vieux on va quand on dit qu'on est
due à 50 ans commence à me devenir
désagréable
donc l'idée vous savez que les règles
d'indemnisation
ces deux ans avant 50 ans c'est trois
ans après nous voudrions suivre
l'évolution de la retraite et est
considérée comme passe à trois ans qu'à
partir de 54 55 ans tout pour tout
regarder exactement le même destin
restaurant fin pour le volet économie
aurait beaucoup d'autres choses à dire
tout l'assurance maladie là il faut
qu'on se parle clair et et tenir compte
des leçons de ce qui arrive des
mésaventures qui arrive à françois
hollande il a menti et dans ses
mensonges de la campagne était contenue
l'échec de son quinquennat
donc il faut qu'on dise la vérité sur
l'assurance maladie ne peut pas rester
dans cette situation là on ne peut pas
le taux de remboursement des médicaments
c'est 76% c'est l'un des plus élevés
d'europe voire du monde
bien sûr parce que le rhdp yonne système
social le plus avancé
quand vous dites plus élevés d'europe et
pas prêts loin de plus élevés du monde
nous proposons de le ramener à 73%
mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis
c'est deux milliards d'euros d'économies
par points
c'est pas rien je n'ai pas parlé des
heures de travail des 35 heures et tout
ça dans la fonction hospitalière
pourquoi
d'abord parce que madame aubry dans son
bilan pourra s'enorgueillir avis d'avoir
mis la pagaille dans tous les hôpitaux
publics et privés de france parce que
les 35 heures ont totalement désorganisé
les hôpitaux pour une raison très simple
c'est que les hôpitaux sont ouverts du
1er janvier au 31 décembre
h/24 et donc déjà les 35 heures ça bien
paniqué et ça bien désorganisée les
entreprises mais quand vous êtes parent
dont l'organisme de santé qui est ouvert
toute l'année 24 heures sur 24 vous
imaginez le groupe dans notre idée
serait de faire une véritable révolution
de donner l'autonomie aux hôpitaux comme
nous avons donné l'autonomie aux
universités
c'est à dire qu'on leur laisserait le
choix des spécialités le choix christian
du recrutement
le choix de la définition du temps de
travail durée du temps de travail que
nous demande rien en échange
un engagement d'équilibrer est
certainement un regroupement au moins
administratif qui veut pas dire
fermeture ces deux choses très
différentes on peut parfaitement
regroupée des hôpitaux sont est fermé a
pas besoin à chaque fois la voirie de
direction du personnel une direction
s'émeut une direction financière
on peut parfaitement regroupée des
équipements on en a un peu moins de 2000
il faut vraiment arriver à les regrouper
en divisant par deux c'est vraiment
absolument indispensable parce que dans
le même temps il va falloir créer les
conditions du financement d'une nouvelle
pratique médicale car nous ne pouvons
pas rester cercles bref un pays qui
désespère ses médecins
nous avons une des meilleures médecine
parce que nous avons les meilleurs
médecins du monde
si les meilleurs jeunes les meilleurs
étudiants pour pu devenir médecin qui
vous soignera il ya des endroits qui
sont devenues des déserts médicaux
il faut revoir complètement la carte de
la médecine libérale
le financement de l'acte médical et
naturellement nous supprimerons le tiers
payant généralisé qui est la
déresponsabilisation des patients et qui
est inacceptable
alors voilà pour les grandes lignes du
volet économique geie pas si j'étais
assez précis dans les papiers que vous
aurez on peut dire qu'on peut suivre la
discussion encore fait un travail très
sérieux très précis il médias je
remercie encore christian saint-etienne
de son aide incite maintenant la porte
marie christine dalloz maël de callen et
tous ceux qui ont travaillé dessus volet
baisse les impôts très très très
important notre idée serait de voter dès
juillet 2017
toutes les baisses d'impôts du
quinquennat toutes les baisses d'impôts
du quinquennat y compris celles je vais
venir
il s'appliquerait qu'avec un délai de
deux ans deux ans près pourquoi parce
que on a deux objectifs d'abord mettre
fin à l'instabilité fiscale
on peut plus avoir d majorité y compris
la nôtre je prends toute ma part de
responsabilité qui s'amuse à changer les
règles en permanence parce que dès qu'un
ministre arrive il veut mettre son nom
une réforme est allé l'autre jour
c'était très amusant c'était devant une
fondation très sympathique moment tout
le monde est sympathique
ma situation
fondation concorde il disait il faut
plus d'économie ou plus de libéralisme
et cetera les trois premières questions
c'était trois demandes de dépenses
supplémentaires
je ne veux pas j'aurais dit d'ailleurs
très gentiment 3-2 maintenant alors donc
là là notre idée serait de voter une loi
fiscale sur tout le quinquennat avec un
premier volet qui s'appliquerait dès
l'année suivante dès 2018 une baisse de
toutes les tranches de lire pp de 10%
forfaitaire pourquoi 10%
on peut discuter à l'infini mais dans
notre idée c'est d'envoyer un message
aux classes moyennes qu'ils ne seront
pas les oubliés de l'alternance alors
après on peut discuter
est-ce que ça s'est passé moi je pense
que 10%
c'est très significatif et on applique à
toutes les tranches et ap
deuxièmement il ya un problème de
famille immense mais enfin c'est quand
même invraisemblable il ya 250 malades
de la smr de plus chaque année
pourquoi je le dis parce que quand on a
un membre de sa famille qu'un éphémère
ça veut dire le recours à des emplois
familiaux
la quasi totalité des femmes en tout cas
des jeunes femmes aspirent et ou d'un
travail et on peut pas leur demander en
étant 2016 on va pas demander aux femmes
de devoir arbitrer entre le désir de
maternité et le désir d'indépendance par
le travail alors on n'a rien compris à
ce que l'évolution de la société
donc il ya un besoin d'emplois familiaux
eh bien figurez vous que malgré ces deux
phénomènes
c'est la première fois depuis dix ans
que le nombre d'emplois familiaux
diminue en france
nous sommes un pays qui a six millions
de personnes sans emploi il ya un
million de chômeurs de plus depuis que
monsieur hollande est là
et le nombre d'emplois familiaux diminue
mais c'est une contradiction terrifiante
par rapport à la réalité de la situation
économique qui est la nôtre
pourquoi ces diminue parce qu'ils n'ont
cessé de renier les défiscalisations
possible ce qui est absurde parce que
l'entreprise ne paye pas dit s sur sa
masse salariale puisque elle déduit les
salaires et les charges de sa masse
salariale de son chiffre d'affaires
avant de calculer le bénéfice la famille
qui a un emploi familiale elle paye le
rpp sur le salaire et sur les charges
donc notre objectif c'est de décharger
les emplois familiaux pour relancer la
création d'emplois familiaux et ses
emplois c'est des emplois de nea qui a
des gens pardon qui ont souvent pardon
de formation peu de possibilité
d'accéder à des emplois extrêmement
qualifiés et donc ça aide les familles
ça soutient la politique familiale et ça
crée des emplois pour des gens qui n'ont
pas forcément la possibilité de trouver
immédiatement un emploi dans la start up
extrêmement moderne mondiale sans
cravate
il faut des emplois pour tout le monde
et tout le monde n'est pas j'en sais
quelque chose
un formidable délier de l'ordinateur
donc il nous semble qu'il faut corriger
la politique fiscale de la gauche sur la
fiscalité des aides des emplois
familiaux et il faudra sans doute revoir
les questions de quotient je veux redire
que je suis totalement opposé la
fiscalisation des allocations familiales
parce que la politique familiale n'est
pas une politique de redistribution des
revenus mais de soutien à l'arrivée d'un
enfant
3 nous voulons faire un geste majeur
pour les charges parce que ce que nous
voulons c'est soutenir l'emploi
alors le la gauche et un vent de cic ils
ont ils ont mis quatre ans pour
comprendre que c'était ingérable
ça pourrait être pire ils auraient pu
mettre cinq ans six ans je crois qu'ils
pourront pas pour des raisons qui
tiennent aux français mais en mai quatre
ans pour comprendre ça donc notre idée
c'est de prendre les 17 milliards du
cicr pour les mettre immédiatement en
baisse de charges massives sur les
emplois parce que la bombe atomique
française des 6 millions de chômeurs ne
peut être traité de façon efficace que
par une baisse des charges pour
encourager les entreprises à créer des
emplois
on rajoutera tels que milliards de plus
pour décharger complètement les emplois
au niveau du smic et pour qu'ils aient
des avantages des charges jusqu'à ce x
1,6 alors ça c'est un débat économique
très difficile
je comprends l'argument de ceux qui me
disent mais enfin on doit accueillir des
emplois les plus performants donc il
faudrait des charges est en haut de la
pile oui et non on n'embauche pas un bac
+ 18 parce qu'on a un avantage sur les
charges dans une situation idéale si on
avait les moyens
il faudrait sans doute le faire aussi
mais on l'a pas donc nous préférons
encourager le recours à l'emploi pour
ceux de nos compatriotes qui sont plus
le plus longtemps au chômage qui ont le
moins de formation et qui ont un âge où
c'est plus difficile de retrouver un
emploi plutôt que d'encourager de toit
en toit de jeunes très qualifiés qui
théoriquement dans une économie qui
retrouverait de la croissance peuvent
s'en sortir par eux-mêmes
voilà l'arbitrage que
nous souhaitons rampe et enfin
suppression immédiate de liesse f alors
je veux dire un mot sur ce sujet parce
que c'est pas rien c'est un peu moins de
5 milliards d'euros
je veux m'en expliquer avec vous on peut
parfaitement vouloir garder les sf mais
dans ce cas là faut sortir de l'europe
si on veut rester en europe comme le
souhaitons on ne peut pas être les seuls
vous m'entendez bien les seuls à garder
un impôt qui n'existe nulle part
ailleurs
ou alors on va continuer à faire fuir
des gens qui ont des moyens qui
pourraient investir en france et qu'ils
vont dépenser en belgique en suisse aux
états unis et ailleurs
alors que la france on a bien besoin
donc la question de l' isf que j'avais
cru à tort tranché en le mettant dans le
bouclier fiscal
moyennant quoi j'ai pas eu tous les
avantages j'ai eu tous les désavantages
non retour d'expérience instruits par
tout cela on le supprime et on le dit si
vous êtes dans un système européen où
les personnes et les biens peuvent
circuler et que vous créez des impôts
qui n'existent pas chez vos voisins vous
encourager par vos prestations sociales
un certain nombre de gens pour qu'ils
vous n'avez pas d'emploi à venir et vous
décourager par vos impôts des gens dont
vous avez besoin pour qu'ils
investissent dans l'économie française à
partir c'est quand même pas le but d'une
équipe gouvernementale qui voudraient
faire de la france un pays moteur
voilà je crois je n'ai rien oublié pour
cette première étape mais nous voudrions
faire voter une deuxième étape faire
voter dès 2017 avec application deux ans
après parce que tout ce que nous avons
nos hypothèses sont extrêmement
raisonnable puisque on any protège de
croissance à 1,5
nos hypothèses de déficit c'est la
stabilité dans un premier temps pour
arriver à un excédent de + 0 4
fin du quinquennat c'est pour ça que
nous demandons un décalage de deux ans
pour faire quoi pour faire une chose qui
est absolument incontournable
nous sommes le pays d'europe qui à la
fiscalité de l'épargné
la plus pénalisante nous ne pouvons pas
rester comme cela je crois qu'on est aux
alentours de 45 % entre si vous
additionnez prélèvements sociaux et
prélèvements maintenant serait simple
mieux que moi
eric aussi c'est pas possible et quand
on me dit mais enfin tu ne peux pas
faire que la fiscalité de l'épargné soit
plus bas sur la fiscalité du travail
excusez moi c'est une bêtise parce que
la fiscalité de l'épargné d'une
fiscalité de second rang et donc elle a
déjà été purgée
si vous me permettez cette expression
soit par l'impôt sur le revenu soit pour
les impôts sur la consommation soit mon
cher daniel par les impôts sur les
successions
donc on ne peut pas être en europe et y
avoir une fiscalité à ce point
désastreuses sur les revenus de
l'épargné dans j'ajoute pas changé
d'avis de ce point de vue quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie qu'on a payé des
impôts
il est normal de transmettre en
franchise d'impôt le fruit d'une vie de
travail à ses enfants
je souhaite qu'on revienne à ce que
j'avais fait sur les 168 d'euros
d'exonérations pour les donations ce qui
d'abord je suis désolé mais moralement
moralement c'est quand même mieux de
privilégier celui des agents économiques
qui met de côté pour les générations
futures au pour sa retraite plutôt que
celui qui dépense tout est donc à ce
moment là il me semble que celui qui a
travaillé paie ses impôts il ya le droit
de garder le mot patrimoine le mont
propriété c'est pas des gros mots c'est
quand il faut quand même qu'on ait le
courage merci madame
demain je suis à annonçant si vous
voulez revenez ce besoin de votre
soutien
c'est quand même est extrêmement
important et par ailleurs claude
économiquement marianne aussi c'est très
important parce qu'économiquement ça
permet de passer l'argent d'une
génération plus âgée vers une génération
plus jeune
or les jeunes consomment plus que les
moins jeunes etc c'est bon pour la
croissance et pour l'économie
deuxième volet troisième et dernier
c'est pour vous dire qu'il ya du boulot
mais c'est le volet du code du travail
non mais alors avec eric on s'est posé
beaucoup de questions je excusez moi je
peux citer tout le monde pierre
lequiller président küster marianne
constance mais on essaie de saintes et
les conventions mais forcément il ya des
sujets qui qui se recroisent alors ce
que tu travailles d'abord je veux mettre
en garde contre une idée fausse parce
que trop simple qui consiste à dire le
code du travail que 3000 pages on le
ramène à 501 aura plus de problème c'est
absurde parce que si vous avez un code
du travail à 500 les tribunaux
s'engouffreront dans la brèche et
remplaceront par la jurisprudence
ce que les législateurs ont reçu primé
par la loi la nature ayant horreur du
vide
nous voulons d'abord refonder
complètement le modèle de démocratie
sociale
ce qui veut dire que nous disons et nous
prévenons les grandes centrales
syndicales que nous supprimerons le
monopole de présentation des candidats
des grandes centrales
mickeal au premier tour ce qui veut dire
pour être concret que dans les
entreprises il n'y aura plus qu'un seul
tour en tout cas y'a pas un premier tour
où seul c'est exactement comme si on
disait à ce formidable nom doit se
présenter aux élections qu'un candidat
des socialistes un candidat des
républicains rapport peut faire mieux
qu'un candidat des républicains
d'après eux mêmes on peut même affiner
le système c'est un truc et ça dure
depuis 1945 sont tranquilles et on est
représentative des bruits vous êtes les
seuls candidats
avec ça il n'y a pas trop de concurrence
vous gêne pas non et pas ça c'est pas
possible c'est fini
chacun a le droit de se présenter aux
élections et les salariés décideront
librement de thierry représente deuxième
c'est un petit changement deuxième mais
faut avouer déjà pardonné puisqu'en le
dis on défendra comme ça tout le monde
est prévenu
deuxièmement je suis désolé il ya
quelque chose de profondément anormal
c'est la possibilité désigné dans une
entreprise un délégué syndical qui était
battu aux élections
donc nous disons il n'y aura plus de
délégués syndicaux désigné ignorante des
délégués syndicaux et du sivu est
délégué syndical un problème mais lui
oui on va y avoir un délégué qui est
battue dans l'élection au deuxième tour
mais qui est renommé pas une centrale
syndicale
et oui et quand il s'y met accord si
tokyo parce qu'ils sont ou qui refusent
de signer les accords ensuite parce que
c'est là la différence de caractère
entre eric woerth et moi
le gentil le positif disons le lucide et
l'expérimenté troisième chose dans les
entreprises où il n'y a pas de syndicat
on n'y aurait pas d'accord nous voulons
généraliser le référendum d'entreprise
un homme une femme une voix une voix de
plus l'accord effet nous voulons passer
d'une démocratie de la confrontation à
une démocratie de la concertation c'est
dans l'entreprise dans un dialogue
fructueux et confiant entre le chef
d'entreprise et les salariés qu'on
décide une chose aussi importante par
exemple de la durée du temps de travail
les entreprises qui veulent rester aux
35 heures resteront 35 heures
celles qui veulent passer à 38 heures
passeront à 38 heures payer 38 essais
les salariés qui discuteront avec le
chef d'entreprise de la durée du temps
de travail mais nous accompagnerons cela
par un changement dans la loi aubry -
vous travaillez plus vous avez
d'exonérations de charges
ben non on va faire un système qui
presque le même
plus on travaille plus on aura
d'exonération de chasse aux résultats
c'est pas le même résultat
non donc on change complètement les
règles du fonctionnement de la
démocratie sociale et on donne de la
souplesse
enfin il me semble qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est essentielle
c'est après que nous ayons fait la
rupture par consentement mutuel qui est
un grand succès la possibilité donnée
une entreprise de séparer d'un salarié
pour une région économique va me dire
mais ça existe
non car aujourd'hui c'est le tribunal
qui juge en opportunité et non pas en
égalité
autrement dit l'entreprise xc part de
monsieur durand parce qu'elle a perdu un
marché c'est le tribunal qui considèrent
si oui ou non le chef d'entreprise y
avait le droit de le faire
nous voulons un système différent le
tribunal n'aurait à vérifier que la
réalité de la perte du marché
les conséquences économiques de la perte
du marché
c'est le chef d'entreprise à qui on doit
faire confiance qui peut l'analyser
sinon il faut attendre que l'entreprise
sont en faillite pour lui permettre de
se séparer de collaborateurs qu'elle ne
pouvait plus garder et on est à la
catastrophe et on perd plus d'emplois et
on a plus de chômeurs voilà mais
mesdames et messieurs je pense que je
dis à peu près rien oublié il ya encore
tellement d'autres choses à dire
pour terminer pour conclure j'évolue
créé républicain est un projet politique
je ne voulais pas qu'on attende les
primaires parce qu'un parti politique
qui n'a pas projet politique c'est un
club de supporters
j'ai rien contre les clubs de supporters
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi tous mes
amis auraient travaillé comme ça donc ce
que nous vous présentons ici tout son
sens c'est le projet merci il croit que
je suis capable de faire plein de choses
à la fois papier tient qu'à nous
remettre n'a rien à voir avec ce que je
dis merci de m'avoir bien interrompu non
je te ferai la chose la prochaine fois
donc un parti politique qui n'a pas de
projets ce n'est pas un parti politique
donc c'est le projet des républicains
sur lequel vous allez avoir à voter pour
dire si vous êtes d'accord ou pas
d'accord
abriel et primaire libre aux candidats
des primaires d'aller plus loin ou
d'aller moins loin libre même à eux de
dire on se reconnaît pas du tout dans
projets des républicains vous en tirer
les conséquences
mais le pré le parti que je préside aura
un projet politique sur tous les sujets
dans l'alternance c'est une question de
respect tout n'est pas une question
d'ego tous les pannes questions de
personnes nous devons aux français la
franchise sur la vérité de l'état de
notre pays sur les voies et les moyens
pour sortir le pays de la situation dans
lequel il se trouve voilà pourquoi
non seulement il ya toutes les
conventions régime
non seulement vous voter à chaque fois
mais on fera un conseil national en juin
pour récapituler l'ensemble des
engagements et ses désengagements de la
famille c'est très important je précise
pour vous dire que hier on a une réunion
vraiment positive est intéressant sur
les investitures aux législatives comme
je les propose et nous investirons nos
candidats entre le 1er juin et 14
juillet parce que je souhaite que pour
une fois les partis politiques de la
droite et du centre soit prêt pour les
élections et ne soit pas en retard donc
un an avant nous donnerons les
investitures dans les circonscriptions
législatives
ça fait l'objet d'un accord unanime et
s'il devait y avoir un problème
politique ou un autre sur 577
circonscriptions on sortira les quelques
circonscriptions où il y aurait un
problème politique et on attendra
tranquillement mais si j'écoutais ce
qu'on me disait pas de projet pour le
parti pas d'investiture il reste quoi et
pourquoi vous m'auriez élu président de
la famille je n'ai pas cette conception
d'un président quatrième république
par parenthèse
grâce à vous au nombre d'adhérents
rembourser nos dettes
plus personne ne parle d'ailleurs
évidemment on parle pas des trains qui
arrivent à l'heure
et il ya de plus en plus de militants d'
adhérents à jour de cotisation merci
infiniment
vous savez qu'en juin jour de semaine
comme cela vient tant de parlementaires
que je remercie notamment le trésorier
qui dit regarde s'ils se dépense pas
trop si vous croyez qu'il est facile
avec moi c'est vous le connaissez pas un
et tant de gens dans la salle un jour de
semaine
c'est un encouragement pour nous
approfondir le projet affiché en plus on
le fait en présence des observateurs de
la presse
on en débat il peut y avoir des
désaccords ces désaccords c'est une
richesse
si chacun les met au service d'un projet
collectif
voilà donc ça c'est le travail jusqu'en
juin après on entamera une autre période
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler merci
de votre attention
merci de votre participation et je vais
céder la parole à marie christine c'est
toi qui donne une question assez
christian qui va le leu leu donner un
j'ai hâte